[音楽]
[拍手]
ここまで
すごい
名だたる方々がお話をしていただいた後に
ね私がこんな話をするのはすごく僭越なん
ですが今高さの話を聞いて皆さん心が
若返ったと思いますのでここから先は
赤ちゃんぐらいの気持ちで聞いて
いただければなと思いますそれに合わせて
スライドも作ってきたのでぜひ
メガネをみんなが今ちょっとすごいまとも
なこと書いてますけどこんなことしゃべら
ないので
気楽に聞いていただければなと思いますと
いうことで改めまして皆さんこんにちは私
初音と申します
ご存知の方もおられるかもしれませんが私
streamerという職業をね現在させ
ていただいております
そうそれは何でしょう
ちょっと笑ってほしいですねこういう
スライドはいということでですね
ストリーマーという職業というのを
改めて今回
説明からねさせていただこうかなと思い
ます
主にですねゲームやトークを
インターネット上で配信して
リスナーの方とコミュニケーションを取り
ながら私はですね私はですねもともとプロ
ゲーマーのあるキャリアを生かして
トーク動画やゲーム配信などを主に投稿し
ております最近ではですねインターネット
上では24時間常に配信をつけてる方だっ
たりそう寝てる姿をね配信している方だっ
たりもう何でもあり
他人の生活をちょっと覗き見するような
こう不思議なジャンルなんかも
流行っているようですということで
突然ですが皆さんは普段ゲームで遊んだり
しますか
幸いなことに私はですね
ストリーマーという職業から
毎日ゲーム三昧の日々を送らせていただい
ているのですがこの会場にいる皆さんは
どんなのどんな感じでしょうか今でこそ
かなり一般的な趣味になっているので
普段から自分自身がゲームで遊ぶよって
いう方も多いんじゃないでしょうかこの中
に
自身もしくは
ご家族息子さん娘さんだったりが
ゲームをプレイしていて生活の中にゲーム
が身近な方ってどれぐらいいらっしゃい
ますか
半分ぐらい出すね
[笑い]
わかりましたねそう最近ではだいぶ増え
ましたがこれがあと今5年前に私がこの
ステージに立っていたら
多分
手がねほんま上がらなかったんじゃないか
なと思いますこれは
ゲームをやっているEスポーツ業界の人間
としてはすごくゲーム冥利に尽きること
ですそんな
ゲームもですねほんの20年前までは
まだまだ黎明期で
オタクがやるものとね決めつけられていた
ような
存在でした
正直私もゲームをしているということは
これで小学生なんですけどだいたい高校生
ぐらいになるまで
周りの友達に隠してましただ
オタク
じゃんと思われてしまうのがすごく
恥ずかしいと思っていたからですさてなぜ
そんな私が今この場にストリーマーとして
たっているのか
そんなね初目の歴史を今日は話したいと
思います私がゲームと出会ったのは幼稚
園生の頃でしたというのも
父親がね
めちゃめちゃゲームが好きだったんです
お父さんのFacebookから勝手に
撮りました
そういうのもですね私の両親あまり両親の
関係者が良くなくていわゆる仮面夫婦の中
に
初音ちゃん生まれ育ちましたでその中で私
が唯一父親とコミュニケーションをとる
方法が
ゲームだったのです
父親が家に帰ってきて
ポーズが珍しくパソコンに向かって
楽しそうにゲームな遊んでいるそんな
ゲームと向かう父の背中を見て育った私も
ある種必然的にゲームをやるようになって
いったのです
私はですねプロゲーマー時代父の背中と
いうチームに所属していましたまさに
父の背中を見て
当時海外でも若かった私は
他のゲーマーの先輩の
父親のような背中を追いかけて
必死にプロジェダイを過ごせました
これにはちょっとうまいこと言ったつもり
なんですけど大丈夫ですかね
はいということでですね
お願いします次に
ありがとうございます今ではどんな大勢の
方の前でいかにも時代の最先端の成功者
みたいな立ち振る舞いで猫とお話しさせて
いただいていますがそんな私も小学生の頃
は
すっごく根暗な部分があって
ずっとなんとなく今の自分が嫌だなと
自己嫌悪があった記憶がありますただ
ゲームをしている時だけは別でした私3名
はですね岡村鈴音というのですが
発明という名前
新しいのかぶった時に
自分の新しい側面を見つけられたような気
がして
発明であるそんな自分はすごく好きでした
あと
ゲームをやっていた時になぜかすごく早く
お隣になりたいなと思っていたことがあっ
て
ゲームの中のフレンドや
共闘するチームメンバーに対して
すごく恥ずかしいんですけど年齢をね
偽ってみたりだとかこう少し背伸びをして
大人っぽく振る舞うとか
傍から見たらそういうしょうもない一面が
自分にとってはすごく大事な一面でした
早く大人になりたかった
自分は
周りとは違うと思うある種の
完璧主義だったのかなと今では思ってい
ます
そんな子供時代を過ごした私の天気となり
ましたのは高校時代に
秋葉原に
ゲームのイベントの専用の施設があって
まあ
ライブハウスのゲーム版だと思って
いただければ簡単かなと思いますそこで
ですね高校生から大学1年生ぐらいまで
アルバイトをしていた時でしたここからが
ね私の人生の天気の瞬間ですこの会場の中
にこのタイトルをしている方がどれくれる
かわかりませんが
ウルトラストリートファイター4
ウルフオーと呼ばれる格闘ゲームの大会の
日にたまたまお店に忘れ物を取りに行った
んですねでその時に今まで格闘ゲームの
大会を見たことはなかったんですが
ステージ上で戦う格闘ゲームの選手の人
たちの姿が
めちゃめちゃかっこよく見えたんです
まあというのも当時私はFPSと呼ばれる
5人対5人と行う銃撃戦のゲームをやって
いましたでもやっぱり私は周りに比べて
子供でそして
男性社会の中で
唯一女性でどうしても周囲の一つからの
ヘイトがすごく高くて
当時15歳ぐらいだったんですけどその時
に40歳近い自分のお父さんぐらいの方と
ね年齢が変わらない方にも
怒られたり大学生ぐらいの人にはおられ
たり
勝ち負けのなすり付き合いのようなそう
いうものにすごくうんざりしていました
そんな私は1対1の
勝っても負けても全てが自分に返ってくる
勝って嬉しいことも負けて悲しいことも
全部が自分のもので
自分の成果で
誰かを感動させることができるそんな格闘
ゲームに魅了させる
魅了されてしまったのです
こうして格闘ゲームの世界に足を踏み入れ
た私は大会の参加者の方々に格ゲーのなっ
たのかを教わりながらどんどん実力と
そして心の金運を高めていきました
そして高校3年生になった時私でも人生の
一大イベント進路選択が迫ってきました
高校生から大学に進学する時ってほとんど
の方が人生で初めて行う人類の
進路選択なんじゃないかなと思っているん
ですが
当時の自分は大学に行きながら広告代理店
卒業後は代理店に就職してゲーム大会を
作ったりゲームをサポートする場合もある
かなーなんて考えたりして実際英語
ニュースを受けたりもしていましたそんな
時
突然体調を崩して1ヶ月近く入院をして
当時中の良かった友達がお見舞いの時に
持ってきてくれたあるプロゲーマーの方が
書いた本が私の人生を変えました
それが
格闘ゲーム界のレジェンド
梅原大吾さんと
ブロガーであるツキリンさんの著書
悩みどころと逃げ所その本の一節に
梅原さんとこんな言葉がありますこの言葉
は私の人生を変えたとても大切な言葉なの
でこの場では梅原さんのお
言葉をお借りして皆さんにお伝えしたいと
思います
自分が経験したあまりにも残酷なごめん
なさいあまりにも過酷な世の中の現状も
しっかり伝えたいいや
伝えないといけない
本当に大変なんだぞって何度も脅かして
それでも行きますこれはいきますってやつ
だけがこっち側に来ればいい
この言葉を聞いて入院中の病床で私はあ私
はそっち側に行かなきゃ今行かなきゃと
思い退院した後に
両親に土下座をして大学の入学を辞退し
ました
ちなみに両親はですねまあどうせそうなる
と思ってたよって
言ってくれましたありがとうございます
本当にお母さんとお父さんそして
自信をつけてくれたのは女性でゲームが
うまいということの価値だったわけです
FPSプレイヤーの頃は
女性があることはマイナスでしたが
視点を変えてみればそれは自分にとっての
追い風でしたそして
ゲーム界隈でも年齢層の高い格闘ゲームと
いうフィールドで18歳がプロを目指すと
いう付加価値
正直な話大学に行きながらプロの水を
たどっていく
選択肢もありましたただ私は完璧主義の
わがままなので
常に自分が
道を切り開く側で言いたい私が先頭で私が
人柱になっててもこのEスポーツ業界をし
ていきたいそう思いましたまさにこれが
社会の風潮を逆手に取った考え方だったの
です
そこから当時18歳のちんちくりんの初音
さんはですね自分で名刺を作ったり
当時働いてたお店で出会ったゲームの関係
者の方に
飯配ってなんか昨日は飯交換ありがとう
ございますみたいなメールを送って
とにかく自分を売り込みまくりましたその
結果高校卒業後の4月に
晴れてプロゲーマーになり3年間の活動を
コロナにより大会が行えないため一体今は
同じゲームの職業とするストリーマーとし
て活動しています
こうやって振り返ってみるといろいろな
ことがありました今日お話ししたこともね
本当に一部なんですけどいろんなことが
ありました
簡単に今話した天気だけまとめるとこんな
感じですでここから
共通して大切なのは
外からの風を受けて自分の心の数をどう
動かしていくかだと思ったのです
なんか突然スピリチュアルな話をしますが
でもこうやって表現するのが一番いいのか
なと思いましたまず風って何かの話をさせ
ていただきたいと思います
自分には2種類の数が吹いていると思い
ます1つ目は自分を取り巻く風もう一つが
自分の心の数です
自分を取り巻く数というのは
他人の言葉だったり
世の中の風潮社会の環境など私がプロ
ゲーマーデビューした頃はプロゲーマー
なんて言葉が浸透しておらずこう別に大学
行きながらの
目指せばとかなんて
言うんですかね
安定しなくて
夢のまた夢の職業そんなものを目指す
くらいなら大学行きながらでもいいじゃん
そんな風潮のある時代でした
言い換えれば自分が進みたいと思う別には
すごく不快風が吹いていました
でもそんな中で自分の背中を押してくれる
向かい風が
ごめんなさい追い風がいくつも存在しまし
た
掲げよう教えてくれる大会の参加者の方々
悩んだ時に読んだプロゲーマーの本何より
初めてゲームの道ゲームという数を起こす
のは
自分自身の父親だったわけです
自分の周りを取り巻く風によって
自分自身の行動もね変化していくと思い
ますもう一つの数が自分の心の風です
何より
自分がやりたいと思わなければ何も
踏み出せない
自分が続けたいと思わなければ続けられ
ないのです私今でも時々大学行けばよかっ
たなぁとか
ゲームが嫌いになりそうだなーとか今もう
この業界に入った8年も経つんですけれど
もいまだにそういう
不安が大阪かかりますでも好きを仕事に
するっていうのはそういうことなんです
たまにもうあと戻りできないからまだで
待ってるんだろうっていうことを投げかけ
られます
そうではなくて私は心の底からこのゲーム
というコンテンツを愛しているから
多少いまだにこの業界にいます
いろんなきっかけは自分の心を取り巻く風
が起こしてくれました
でもそれだけじゃ足りないんです
ゲームが好きだとか
負けず嫌いだとかそういう自分のすごく
ピュアな部分から吹いてくる心の風に
思いっきり乗っかっていくことが大事な
大切じゃないかなと思います
プロゲーマーから始めた自分のキャリアは
今やストリーマーです
格ゲーのプロから
FPSのストリーマーです何もかも
いろんな風を
捉えてそして乗っかり続けた結果なのです
もちろんこう
素振りしてたらたまたまあ弾当たって
ホームラン打っちゃったなんてことも
もちろんありましたでも思い立ったら勢い
と共に動く
自分の最大瞬間風速を捉えて動くことが
自分の転機となっていた気がします
最後になりますが日常生活にはですね色々
な風が吹いています私の場合それはプロ
ゲーマーという職業に対する偏見の逆風
だったり
格ゲープレイヤーという
男性社会の中で女性のあることだったりで
もそういう逆風も
考えようによっては
追い風にできるのかもしれません
No1より婚礼ワンでありたいそこが2回
風を
追い風に変える視点なのかもしれません
他にも子供の頃一緒にゲームをしていた父
の背中や
プロとして戦う選手たちが憧れだったり
負けず嫌いだったりねやっぱりだったり
自分の本当にピュアなところから吹いて
くる衝動のような
内側から吹いてくるものももちろんあると
思います
日々にね
本当いろんな風が吹いているんですそれを
皆さんも日々感じ取ってその最大瞬間風速
を逃さないように一番
自分を進めてくれる風にとってみては
いかがでしょうかもちろんどんな結果に
なるかわからないんですけれどもちょっと
冒険主義でも人生すごく楽しいと思います
私もですね
嫌な経験辛い経験こう
精神的に
ダメージを受けた
経験がありますがそれでも今
ストリーマーとしてここに立っています
好きなことを仕事にするということは
好きなことが嫌いになってもいいことを
持たないといけない私はいつまでもゲーム
を愛しそんな私を愛してくれるファンの皆
様と
周りの優しい大人
めっちゃ緊張してますまだ
ごめんね
改めましていつまでも私はゲームが大好き
だしそんな私を
愛してくれるファンの方と
周りの優しい大人たちからたくさんの
追い風を
受けて
逆風を跳ね返してこれからも新しい店を
開いていきたいと思いますということで
ご清聴ありがとうございました